>> AS DETAILS OF THE MAIL BOMB
SCARE SUSPECT COME IN, SOME
TRUMP CRITICS IN THE MEDIA ARE
TRYING TO BLAME THE PRESIDENT.
>> HE SPENDS MOST OF HIS TIME AT
RALLIES DURING VERBAL BOMBS AT
ALL THE PEOPLE THAT RECEIVE
THESE BOMBS IN THE MAIL.
>> THERE IS NEVER ANY
ACKNOWLEDGMENT OF OWNERSHIP ON
HIS PART THAT HE'S FUELING THESE
FLAMES.
HE SAYS HE WANTS A MESSAGE OF
UNITY YET HE LEADS RALLIES WHERE
HIS SUPPORTERS STILL CHANT "LOCK
HER UP" WHEN HE CALLS PEOPLE THE
ENEMY OF THE PEOPLE.
>> OF COURSE THE PRESIDENT
DIDN'T DIRECT THIS.
BUT HE IS RESPONSIBLE FOR NOT
JUST ALLOWING THE CHANTS "CNN
SUCKS" BUT STOKING IT, AND ALL
YOU NEED IS ONE CRACKPOT AND ONE
YOU NEED IS ONE CRACKPOT AND ONH
YOU NEED IS ONE CRACKPOT AND ONS
EMERGED.
>> HE DID NOT MENTION THIS
INCIDENT OR PRESIDENT TRUMP BUT
DID TALK ABOUT CIVILITY.
>> I'M HOPING YOU THINK AS WELL
TO HEAR PEOPLE SPEND YEARS,
MONTHS, VILIFYING PEOPLE.
QUESTIONING THEIR PATRIOTISM.
CALLING THEM ENEMIES OF THE
PEOPLE.
SUDDENLY YOU ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
CIVILITY.
WE CAN HAVE DISAGREEMENTS.
BUT THERE HAS TO BE A CERTAIN
CODE, THERE HAS TO BE CERTAIN
RULES IN TERMS OF HOW WE TREAT
EACH OTHER, OPERATE IN THE
PUBLIC SPHERE.
>> THAT SEEMS INTERESTING THAT
JUST A WEEK AGO SAID THAT
HILLARY CLINTON SAID THERE
SHOULDN'T BE CIVILITY, PAM, AND
MAXINE WATERS SAID THE PRESIDENT
PROMOTING VIOLENCE -- AS I
REMEMBER IT, DON'T LET THE
CABINET REST.
DON'T LET HIM EAT A MEAL AT A
RESTAURANT COME LET'S GO AFTER
HIM.
>> GO AFTER SUPPORTERS OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND THAT'S
EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENED TO ME.
I WAS AT A MOVIE THEATER AND IT
WAS THE MAXINE WATERS RHETORIC.
THESE PEOPLE WERE VERBATIM
REPEATING THE MAXINE WATERS
TALKING POINTS, SCREAMING IN MY
FACE STOPPING ME.
AFTER IT HAPPENED TO ME, AFTER
IT HAPPENED TO SARAH SANDERS,
AFTER IT HAPPENED TO KIRSTJEN
NIELSEN, SHE DOUBLED DOWN, SHE
SAID IT AGAIN.
TO CONTINUE AND BLAME IT ON THE
PRESIDENT IS DISGRACEFUL.
THE FIRST THING PRESIDENT TRUMP
THAT IS, AND CONDEMN THESE
ACTIONS.
>> COME ON!
THAT'S UNBELIEVABLE.
EVEN IN THE MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT,
PRESIDENT TRUMP TWEETING AT THE
PRESS IS THE ONE TO BLAME.
THAT'S UNBELIEVABLE.
BUT HERE'S THE THING.
>> THE PRESIDENT IS NOT TO
BLAME.
>> I DON'T THINK THE PRESIDENT
CAN BE DIRECTLY BLAMED BUT YOU
CANNOT IGNORE HIS RHETORIC.
I'M AMAZED TO HEAR PEOPLE
EARLIER IN THE WEEK TALKING LIKE
THIS IS A FALSE BLAST OPERATION,
ITS RELATED DEMOCRATS.
I'M TALKING ABOUT PROMINENT
REPUBLICAN VOICES.
AND COULTER, RUSH LIMBAUGH,
MICHAEL SAVAGE.
"DON'T PAY ATTENTION TO THE
PRESIDENTS RHETORIC."
EVEN THOUGH HE SAYS
HILLARY CLINTON IS EVIL,
BARACK OBAMA WAS A LIAR.
ALL OF THIS HORRIBLE STUFF.
WE ARE NOT ACCUSTOMED TO IT IN
AMERICAN LIFE.
DANA, YOU COVERED SEVERAL
PRESIDENTS.
YOU UNDERSTAND THIS KIND OF
RHETORIC FROM THE PRESIDENT IS
DIFFERENT FROM ANYONE IN THE
WORLD SPEAKING.
>> CAN I ADD ONTO THAT?
>> IT'S DEMEANING AND HUMANIZIN
THAT HUMANIZING.
>> YOU HAD A CAIRO SAYING THE
PRESIDENT WOULD NOT TAKE --
THERE IS NO EVIDENCE HE INCITED
ANYONE.
>> WHAT ABOUT THAT VAN ?
I THINK IT'S CLEAR THAT HIS
PASSIONS WERE AIMED SPECIFICALLY
AT THE TARGETS OF TRUMP'S
RHETORIC.
>> IT'S VERY HARD TO TAKE
LECTURES FROM DEMOCRATS ABOUT
CIVILITY.
LET'S TAKE THE LONG VIEW BACK.
LET'S LOOK AT DECADES.
LET'S LOOK AT THE LAST FEW YEARS
FOR YOU CALL THE PRESIDENT
HITLER, YOU CALL HIM RACIST, YOU
SAY HE'S CLINICALLY INSANE,
MORALLY UNFIT.
THAT'S WITHIN TWO YEARS.
WHO HAS BEEN STOKING ANGER FOR
DECADES?
WHO HAS CLAIMED THAT THE
POLITICAL IS PERSONAL?
MEANING THEY CAN INVADE YOUR
LIFE?
I DON'T WANT LECTURES FROM
PEOPLE WHO BARDEN THE FALN WHO
JUSTIFIED THE MURDER OF
POLICE OFFICERS WHO ALLOWED --
THEY SAID NOTHING ABOUT THE
ASSASSINATION REVENGE FANTASY OF
"THE NEW YORK TIMES," NOTHING
BUT KATHY GRIFFIN, NOTHING ABOUT
JOHNNY DEPP, MADONNA,
SNOOP DOGG?
WHAT ELSE DID THEY DO, THEY FUND
RAISE WITH BILL AYERS?
AN ACTUAL TERRORIST!
I DO NOT WANT LECTURES FROM THIS
PEOPLE ABOUT CIVILITY!
THEY CAN SHOVE IT UP THERE
THEIR TUSH.
I THOUGHT THAT WAS VERY CIVIL.
TUSH WAS A BETTER WORD THAN WHAT
I WANTED TO USE.
I WROTE A BOOK ABOUT "JOY OF
HATE" WHERE I TALKED ABOUT THATA
HATE" WHERE I TALKED ABOUT THATO
HATE" WHERE I TALKED ABOUT THATT
THIS PHENOMENON OF DEMONIZATION
BY ACTIVISTS.
I WROTE THIS WOULD HAPPEN.
I WROTE 13 CHAPTERS OF THIS.
WE TALKED ABOUT THIS ON THE
SHOW.
I CAN'T TAKE A LECTURE FROM
PEOPLE WHO IGNORED ME ABOUT THIS
CONCERN.
>> I'M JUST SAYING IF YOU LOOK
AT CHARLOTTESVILLE --
>> I KNOW.
THOSE ARE THE ONLY ONES YOU
BRING UP.
>> I BRING THAT UP BECAUSE
THAT'S THE REALITY --
>> IN YOUR FILTERED WORLDVIEW.
>> SOMEBODY SAID YOU SHOULD
CONFRONT OFFICIALS --
>> YOU AREN'T CONDEMNING WHAT
MAXINE WATERS SAID AND THEN SET
IT AGAIN AND AGAIN?
>> WE WERE OUT -- WE WERE IN
DALLAS EARLIER THIS WEEK.
A GUY COMES UP TO BECOME A BIG
TRUMP GUY.
HE WANTS AN AUTOGRAPH AND A
PICTURE.
WHAT DOES HE SAY TO ME, I'M
ATTACKING YOU AND YOUR NEW BOOK
AND ALL OF THIS AND CALLED ME A
VILE NAME AND ASKED FOR A
SELFIE.
THIS IS NOT NORMAL BEHAVIOR.
>> THAT'S AWFUL.
TO BE FAIR, THAT WOULD KILL ME.
>> THAT DOESN'T MEAN THE
PRESIDENT IS INCITING PEOPLE.
>> GOING BACK TO JUNE 2015 WHEN
THIS CAMPAIGN GOT STARTED, I WAS
SUPER UNCOMFORTABLE WITH THE
RHETORIC, ALWAYS HAVE BEEN.
A LOT OF PEOPLE SAID TO ME THAT
ONE OF THE REASON PRESIDENT BUS
BUSH'S APPROVAL RATING WAS I DID
NOT FIGHT BACK HARD ENOUGH WITH
LANGUAGE THAT WOULD'VE BEEN
TOPPER
TOPPER.
EVERYBODY RUNNING FOR LANGUAGE
COULD ADMIT AND DO ADMIT THAT
THE RHETORIC WAS -- CIVILITY IS
A CHOICE.
EVERY TIME YOU OPEN YOUR MOUTH,
YOU CAN DECIDE WHAT TO SAY.
>> BUT YOU CAN'T BE LECTURED
ABOUT CIVILITY.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN.
>> NO, I DON'T.
>> YOU KNOW HOW THE LEFT HAS
TREATED CONSERVATIVES.
>> I BELIEVE ABOUT
MITT ROMNEY --
BIG WHAT THEY'VE SAID ABOUT
CONSERVATIVE WOMEN.
>> THIS SHOW WOULD NEVER END IF
WE TALK ABOUT POINT BY POINT
WHEN YOU SAY THAT AND SHE SAID
THAT, AND SEE
SHE SAID THAT, IT
WOULD NEVER END.
90% OF PEOPLE IN AMERICA AGREE
THAT WE ARE TOO DIVIDED RIGHT
NOW.
IF 90% AGREE ON THAT, WE SHOULD
DECIDE TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT
THAT.
>> WE JUST GOT SOME NEW VIDEO OF
THE SUSPECT DOWN IN FLORIDA.
NEW VIDEO THAT'S JUST COMING
INTO OUR NEWSROOM.
YOU CAN OBVIOUSLY SEE HIM BEING
LET IN, HANDCUFFED, OF COURSE.
WE HAD SEEN THE MUG SHOT EARLIER
TODAY.
BUT THIS IS OUR FIRST VIDEO OF
ACTUALLY SEEING THE SUSPECT
BRIEFLY THERE AS HE'S TAKEN
FURTHER INTO CUSTODY.
JUAN, I WONDER YOU'VE GOT
JOE BIDEN THINKING ABOUT RUNNING
FOR PRESIDENT.
HE SAID AMONG OTHER THINGS THIS
WEEK THAT WE SHOULD LOWER THE
TEMPERATURE.
I COVER THE 2012 CAMPAIGN AND
AMONG OTHER THINGS HE WAS
SPEAKING TO A MOSTLY BLACK
AUDIENCE, I REMEMBER, AND HE
SAID THAT MITT ROMNEY WAS GOING
TO PUT YOU ALL BACK AND CHAINS.
HOW DID THAT LOWER THE
TEMPERATURE?
>> THAT'S HEATED RHETORIC --
VEHICLE WHY IS JOE BIDEN
LECTURING DONALD TRUMP?
>> I THINK WHAT PEOPLE ARE
SAYING IS THAT WE ARE INCREDIBLY
DIVIDED AS A COUNTRY AND WE HAVE
A PRESIDENT, A LEADER, WHO
INDULGES IN THE KIND OF
DEMEANING THEM
, W
-- WE GET LOCKED INTO WHAT GREG
WAS JUST DOING, WHAT ABOUT ISM.
>> YOU BEEN DOING THAT FOREVER!
>> SPEECH IS NOT VIOLENCE ANDW
>> SPEECH IS NOT VIOLENCE ANDE
HAVE TO BE ABLE TO SEPARATE
THAT.
WE HAVE A FIRST AMENDMENT.
YOU MIGHT NOT LIKE THE RHETORIC,
BUT THERE ARE PEOPLE ON THE
FRINGE THAT MIGHT REACT CERTAIN
THINGS FROM THE LEFT ON THE
RIGHT AND WE KNOW THAT HAPPENED
TO STEVE SCALISE.
NOBODY SAYS THAT BERNIE SANDERS
IS TO BLAME FOR THAT.
>> OR MSNBC.
WHAT'S INTERESTING IS SOMEBODY
SAID IT ONLY TAKES ONE CRACKPOT,
RIGHT?
ARE WE GOING TO CHANGE THE WAY
WE ARE, 230 MILLION POPULATION,
TO DO THE FAVOR OF ONE CRACKPOT?
THE OTHER POINT IS EVERY BODY IS
LYING ABOUT CIVIL DISCOURSE.
THE PEOPLE THAT ARE SAYING WE
NEED TO TELL HIM -- WHAT THEY
ARE LYING.
I BELIEVE YOU, JUAN.
I DON'T THINK THE DEMOCRATS, THE
MOMENT THEY GET THE CHANCE TO
SCREW YOU FROM BEHIND, THEY
WILL.
THEY DO THAT POLITICALLY,
THEY'LL SAY HORRIBLE THINGS
ABOUT YOU DURING CAMPAIGNS.
AT LEAST TRUMP DOES IT TO YOUR
FACE.
IT'S THE MOST TRANSPARENT INSULT
YOU'LL EVER GET!
IT COMES FROM HIM!
ISN'T THAT HEALTHIER?